hey guys i am driver of team the generation
and I want to share something with you
so just SAY
so I was busy taking 1 testimoniop
from my brother Rafael
and how SAY were talking about healing
SAY only 1 man walked past here and
he was really walking with his bso like this
so I looked at it and I thought
okay but we're busy so I'm just going to leave it
then he said no
GO to him
and ask what's wrong with him with his leg
and I walked over to him
and I asked what was wrong with her leg
and he said
had played football and well now he can't walk said
then I said of
would you mind if i pray for you
because I believe you can get horny through Jesus
then he said yes is good
and then of course I asked her
I prayed for his leg and
at first I wanted to SAY Uhm walk away because I thought of
I wasn't really sure about God at all
then I thought no because he is
certainly the whole SAY
so I really have to believe and trust
that he can actually walk now
and not tonight or tomorrow
so then I let him walk
and when he's on my eyelash eye then he said wow
so I also said wow because I thought wow
and then
then then I said okay you can walk 1 piece
and then yes he went for a walk
and then yes he was actually healed
and he couldn't believe his eyes actually
that through Jesus
actually healed by the Holy Spirit
and he also asked how can
how come you can heal
I actually SAY through Jesus in me and
for me this is really one whole revelation actually
because you can heal
today you can be healed
it is not that you have to walk with you
with your pain with your depression
Jesus is still healing today
it is not something of the bible
from last year
or from millions of years ago thousands of years ago
is still valid today
that you can be cured in his name
and I want to share that with you